اعلنت الحكومه المصريه ابرام عقود لبيع
اصول حكوميه للشركات خاصه بقيمه تصل الى
مليار وتسعمائه مليون دولار وقال رئيس
الوزراء مصطفى مدهولي ان الخطوه جزء من
برنامج الحكومي للطروحات ولا علاقه له
بالازمه الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها مصر
وتاتي هذه الخطوه بالتزامن مع اعلان البنك
المركزي المصري تراجعا شديدا في
الاحتياطات الماليه للبلاد
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في ما وراء الخبر
كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا نناقشه في ثلاثه
مسارات ما هي الاعتبارات والحسابات
الاقتصاديه التي دفعت الحكومه المصريه
لابرام عقود لبيع اصول حكوميه للشركات
الخاصه وهل في ذلك ما يدل على انعطافه في
سياستها على هذا الصعيد
كيف يرى الشركاء الخليجيون للحكومه
المصريه خطواتها الجديده والازمه عموما
لسير مع اعلان البنك المركزي المصري اصول
الاحتياطي النقدي للبلاد الى مستويات
الغير مسبوقه من التدليك وما هي
الانعكاسات المحتمره لسياسه الحكوميه
الجديده على الاقتصاد المصري وعلى الشعب
الذي يعاني اوضاع المعيشيه ضاغطه في الوقت
الراحم
[موسيقى]
دقت ساعه بيع الاصول الحكوميه وها هو رئيس
الوزراء المصري مصطفى مدبولي يعلن وابرام
عقود لخصخصصه اصول الحكوميه للشركات خاصه
لفائده مستثمرين مصريين وصندوق الثروه
السياديه بابو ظبي في الامارات الصفقه
وانحرست الحكومه المصريه على عدم ربطها
بالازمه الاقتصاديه التي تضغط على البلاد
فان اغلب التحليلات تناولتها في علاقه
مباشره بتراجع حاد للاحتياطيات القاهره من
العمله الاجنبيه وفق ما اعلن عنه البنك
المركزي المصري نفسه مدبولي قال ان صافيه
ما سيؤول للحكومه من العقود بالدولار هو
مليار وستمائه وخمسون مليون دولار والباقي
بالجنيه المصري واشار مدبولي الى ان
الحكومه المصريه ستعلن قريبا عن عقود اخرى
بقيمه مليار دولار
صحيفه
اشارت في تقرير لها الى ان سياسه الحكومه
المصريه ترمي الى التاكيد على التزامها
بالاصلاحات التي تفرضها اتفاقيتها مع
صندوق النقد الدولي بقيمه ثلاثه مليارات
دولار للنهوض بالاستثمارات واضافت الصحيفه
ان المستثمرين الخليجيين امتنعوا في
الغالب عن شراء الاصول المصريه لانهم
يتوقعون مزيدا من الانخفاض في الجنيه
المصري
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من القاهره
الدكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب استاذ
الاقتصاد السياسي وخبير الاقتصاد الدولي
ومعنا من الدكتور مصطفى يوسف الباحث في
التمويل الدولي والدراسات الاقتصاديه ومن
الكويت المستشار الاقتصادي علي الانزياء
اهلا وسهلا بكم جميعا وابدا بضيفنا من
القاهره الدكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب
دكتور دكتور دكتور عبد النبي
ما دلاله التوقيت يعني
يفترض ان هنالك مستحقات فوائد ديون ينبغي
ان تسدد تقريبا في هذه الايام وقيمتها
ايضا اثنين مليار دولار هل للامرين علاقه
هل التوقيت مرتبط
بهذه المستحقات على مصر
لا يعني هو التوقيت غير مرتبط بمساله
التزامات الديون الخارجيه المفروضه على
جمهوريه مصر العربيه لكن المشكله ان زي ما
اتى في التقرير ان مصر لديها التزامات
وتعهدات لدى صندوق النقد الدولي ويجب
عليها ان تفي على الاقل بجزء منه حتى
تتاكد انها تسير في طريق الاصلاح التي
تعهدت به
المفاوضات مع الاشقاء في الخليج واضح انها
توقفت مساله سعر الصرف كانت مساله جوهريه
ثم اتضح ان الاقتراب من سعر الصرف في ظل
الظروف الحاليه سوف يؤدي الى كوارث
للمواطن المصري وحتى للدوله المصريه يعني
انت تتحدث عن دولار يساوي اكثر من 30 جنيه
بشكل رسمي يعني حوالي 31 جنيه بشكل رسمي
اذا تم التعويم اللي كان مفترض او اللي
كان منتظر كنت تتحدث عن وصول الدولار الى
40 جنيه او حتى 50 جنيه من هنا ارتقت
الحكومه كحل وسط ان تتجه الى ما نسميه
المستثمر المصري وكما يعلم الجميع ان هناك
حاله من المضاربه على الجنيه والدولار
فبالتاكيد الدولارات التي تم جمعها من
السوق المصريه
ذهبت الى خزائن بعض رجال الاعمال المصريين
ومن هنا كان الاتفاق الوسط ان تعرض تعرض
الحكومه المصريه بدلا من المستثمرين العرب
والخليجين او حتى الاجانب على المستثمرين
المصريين شراء بعض الاصول
الدوله المصريه التي يتم عرضها لكن ان يتم
هذه الصفقات اساسا بجزء يزيد عن 80% منها
بالدولار الامريكي والجزء الباقي بالجنيه
المشكله هنا ان المستثمر المصري لن يهتم
بمساله سعر صرف الجنيه مقابل الدولار او
العكس لانه يعني جمع الحصيله وسوف
يستثمرها داخل بلاده يعني المساله لم تفرق
معه كثيرا لكن عندما كان يتم الامر على
شركاء الخليجين كانت المساله يعني انت
تتحدث عن فرق يزيد عن 20% في سعر العمله
فلماذا يغامر المستثمر الخارجي او
المستثمر الاجنبي بشراء اصول قد تنخفض
قيمتها 20% اذا تم التعويم الجديد
هو رساله موجهه الى صندوق النقد الدولي
والرساله الى المستثمر المصري بان الحكومه
في نيتها لتطبيق القرارات التي اخذتها
مؤخرا وهي المساواه ما بين شركات الحكومه
وشركات القطاع الخاص في الالتزامات
والواجبات طيب دكتور مصطفى يوسف
رئيس الوزراء المصري قال ان هذا غير مرتبط
بالازمه الحاليه لكن ما رايك هل هو مرتبط
او غير مرتبط
يعني في ظني ان الامر مرتبط بمائه بالمائه
لعده اسباب مبدئيا يعني الدكتور مصطفى
مدبولي صرح انه قبل ثلاثين سته سيتم بيع
وصول باكثر من يعني
اثنين مليار دولار وهذا لم يتم الذي تم
بيعه فقط حصه من المصريه للاتصالات وشركه
بكيل للبويات والدهانات بما يوازي تقريبا
147 مليار دولار تقريبا 7% مما تعهد به
وصرح به من قبل الموقف حقيقه يعني انا
اثمن ان يتم بيع الاصول للمستثمرين
المصريين سواء في الداخل رجال الاعمال او
في الخارج لان يعني لدينا اكثر من 11
مليون مصري في الخارج كانوا يحاولون اكثر
من 35 مليار دولار سنويا الان قلد بشده
اكثر من يعني الثلث تقريبا التحويلات
المسلمين في الخارج لانعدام الثقه في
الكفاءه الحكومه وكذلك لخوف هؤلاء
المصريين على ودائعهم الامر يكمن في ان
المستثمرين المصريين حتى داخليا يعني نحن
دوله للاسف منذ قيام الجمهوريه الجديده في
3 يوليو 2013 نستورد اكثر من 70% من
احتياجاتنا سواء غذائيه او السلع الوسيطه
التي تدخل من ضمن الصادرات لماذا زادت
القرود الخارجيه من 43 مليار دولار منذ
قيام الجمهوريه الجديده الاكثر من 165
مليار دولار زادت الديون الداخليه من اكثر
من تريليون جنيه الى اكثر من سته تريليون
ويعني في حين ان الصادرات الغير البترونيه
زادت فقط من 22 مليار الى 35 مليار
ومعظمها في 2021 نتيجه يعني من جراء زياده
اسعار عالميه وتضخم كبير
يعني الامر الذي جعل البنك الدولي وصندوق
النقد الدولي يحذرون من 2019 قبل بدايه
جائحه كوفي 19 بان هناك مشكله كبيره جدا
على اكثر من 60% من المصريين فقراء او تحت
خط الفقر اتى بعد ذلك جائحه كوبي 19
يعني الازمه السلاسل البدو والتوريد ثم
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه والتضخم الكبير
اكثر من 70% طبقا للكثير من التقرير الغير
الرسميه تقول ان المصريين فقراء او تحت خط
الفقر هذا الامر لن يشجع المستثمرين
الاجانب على ان ياتوا لكي يستثمروا في مصر
الامر يقتضي نورا من التغيير الكبير الذي
يعني يجعل يعني خطط التنميه في مقدمه
واهميه يعني وبؤره اهتمام الحكومه المصريه
وليس الانفاق على يعني مشروعات يعني مثل
العاصمه الاداريه الجديده والمونوريل وما
الى ذلك نحن نريد قطب تنميه لدينا في
المغرب الشقيق يعني يعني
مثل جميل يحتذى به المغرب الان يصدر
الاتحاد الاوروبي اكثر من 11 مليار دولار
سنويا صناعه سيارات لان الخط التنميه هناك
اهتمام بالتعليم هناك اهتمام
السيد علي العنازي من الكويت المستشار
الاقتصادي
ما هي الشروط الخليجيه للاستثمار المباشر
ثم نعلم ان هنالك حصص تم شرائها من شركات
كما كالتي اعلن عن الدكتور مصطفى مدبولي
رئيس الوزراء المصري لكن ما هي الشروط
الخارجيه للاستثمار المباشر في مصر
والمقصود طبعا بالاستثمار المباشر هو فتح
مصانع انشاء مشاريع جديده
حقيقه من اهم
يبدو ان السيد علي العنزي ليس معنا اسال
نفس السؤال الدكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب
هل هنالك شروط خليجيه اضافيه عما يعلن عنه
الان
يعني انا لا اعتقد لك شروط اخرى
لكن سياسات سعر الصرف وهذا في حد ذاته امر
في منتهى الخطوره يعني عندما تطالب
يطالب المستثمر الخليجي بوضوح سياسات سعر
الصرف او حتى الوصول لسعر صرف عادل ومستقر
لفتره يضمن له طريقه تمكنه من حساب
الارباح والخسائر فهذا امر مشروع يعني هذا
احد اهم الشروط التي لا يمكن القفز عليها
تحت اي ظروف اخرى اما الشروط الاخرى اللي
هي تحسين تحسين بنيه بنيه ومناخل
الاستثمار
سرعه التقاضي الوصول الى محاكم بالتعويض
يعني تحصيل مناخ الاستثمار هو ان يكون
التقاضي امام بعض المحاكم الخاصه كما
نسميه التحكيم لكن ان يهتم بسرعه ان يكون
هناك وضوح شامل شامل يعني لواجبات
والتزامات اي مستثمر يدخل الى القطاع
المصري الجزء المهم جدا وهو ان تكون
المعامله الضريبيه والجمركيه والقضائيه
على حد السواء ما بين المستثمر المصري
والعربي والاجنبي والاستثمارات المملوكه
للحكومه ولا للقطاعات وللجهات السياديه
هذه الامور في منتهى الاهميه وانا اعتقد
انها ليست شروطا بل هي اساسيات من اجل
تشجيع الاستثمار يعني مساله سعر الصرف
مهمه مساله وضوح القوانين واجراءات
التقاضي مهمه الموقف واضح
الفكره يعود مره يعود الينا مره اخرى
المستشار الاقتصادي السيد علي النازي من
الكويت وكنا نسال عن
توصيف الخليج للازمه في مصر لهذا البيع
للاصول لمناخ الاستثمار في مصر في الوقت
الرائع
حقيقه يجب ان يكون هناك اصلاحات اقتصاديه
واضحه في الاقتصاد المصري للاستمرار في
السياسات السابقه مع الجمهوريه العربيه
جمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه وبالتالي
اعتقد ان بعد عده ازمات اتت في عن الواحد
كورونا ثم بعد ذلك اتت الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه ثم بعد ذلك ارتفاع كبير في
التضخم على المستوى العالمي خلق فجوه
كبيره بين الدول
المتقدمه الدول الناشئه ودول العالم
الثالث التي احدها دوله مصر بالتالي مثل
هذه المشاكل
الحقيقه الاقتصاديه الطارئه
والاستثنائيه خلقت جو غير صحيا للاستثمار
في دول او مساعده دول كعبي حجم مصر فجاءت
المطالبات باصلاحات في الاقتصاد المصري
اعتقد ان بيع الاصول ايضا ياتي من ضمن
الخصخصه من ضمن متطوره للاصل البنك من
وجهه نظر الخليجي والشركاء الخليجين ما هي
الاصلاحات المطلوبه
حتى يصنع
جو الاستثمار في مصر جاذبا
للمستثمر الخليجي
اعتقد برايي الشخص المتواضع اهم الاصلاحات
عمليه الخصخصه محاوله فصخصه قطاعات في مصر
ويقول القطاع الخاص كاداره لانه هو الاكثر
هو المعتمد الان عالميا في دول العالم
المتقدم بالتالي اعتقد ايضا هناك الافصاح
والشفافيه ايضا مهم جدا لدينا في عمليات
الاصحاحات اقتصاديه لقياس ايضا اثر اي
متغيرات اقتصاديه
سعر
المنافسه في السوق هل هو شرط يعني هنالك
من يتحدث عن انه المناخ غير
المنافسه غير عادله في الاقتصاد المصري هل
هذا ما يراه ايضا الخليجيه
طبعا عمليه الاصلاح هي عمليه شامله بكل ما
تعني هذه الكلمه بالتالي عمليه الاصلاح هي
التحول
الخصاصات تحول الخصصه يشترط ايضا حريه
المنافسه منافسه كامله ايضا يشترط بعض
الاصلاحات الاخرى راينا تاثر سعر الجنيه
خلال الفتره الماضيه بشكل حار جدا قد يكون
هناك ظروف للاقتصاد العالمي
كانت قاسيه على الاقتصاد المصري بالتالي
الخليجيون يقيمون كل مرحله لي ايضا
للاستمرار وللعوده مره اخرى للتعاون اكبر
ومساعده ايضا الشقيقه مصر العمليه ليست
عمليه كامله عمليه
اقتصاديه كامله ايضا من من ايضا من باب
الاخوه وايضا الجيره ومكانه نص الشقيقه
لدى الدول الخليجيه وعمق عمق ايضا لهذه
الدول الخليجيه ايضا هو مصر بالتالي عمليه
مساعده مصر يجب ان لا تبنى ايضا على
المنفعه فقط بينما هناك امور اخرى قد تكون
معنويه اكثر وهل هذه الامور في الاعتبار
الان يعني ما تتلاقله وسائل العلامه الصحف
المختصه
على ان المستثمر الخليجي بدل ان اوعدل عن
سياسه الدعم المباشر لمصر عبر الودائع الى
شراء حصص هل هذا يراعي الجانب المعنوي
الذي تحدثت عنه
نعم قد تكون دول خليجيه ايضا مع
هذه ايضا اصلاحات في الدول الخليجيه قد
تكون تحولت الى ايضا
الاستفاده او محاوله الاستفاده من
الفرص الاستثماريه في مصر المستثمر
الخليجي موجود في مصر اعمار موجوده بقوه
في مصر كثير من الشركات الخليجيه موجوده
في السابق في مصر وهناك فرص لماذا الان
ايضا اضافه الى المنافع المعنويه التي
تحدثنا عنه ان يكون هناك منفعه ماليه ايضا
ولكن هي دائما هناك علاقات قد تكون او حتى
الاتفاقات قد تخرج من
سياق ايضا
السياقه الاقتصادي فقط ونذهب الى الامور
ايضا السياسيه وايضا عمليه التعاون
السياسي وايضا التعاون العربي بشكل او
باخر طيب دكتور مصطفى من
ما هي الضوابط من ملاحظاتك الضوابط التي
وضعت لبيع هذه الاصول المصريه
يعني للاسف يعني الان البيع يتم لانقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه نحن نحاول يعني اظهار
التزمنا امام صندوق النقد الدولي والمؤسسه
الدوليه وكذا الشركاء الخليجيين بان مصر
في طريقها الى بعض اصلاحات هيكليه عن طريق
بيع الاصولها احدى الطلبات الطلب الاكبر
الذي طلبه الصندوق هو تخارج المؤسسه
العسكريه من الاقتصاد يعني يعني حينما
يخرج رجل الاعمال بحجم سميح سمير سيقول
انه سينقل اعماله للسعوديه والى دول اخرى
في الخليج نظرا لعدم وجود رؤيه واضحه
وضروبيه المشهد الاقتصادي وعدم وجود سعر
صرف محدد وكذا لوجود مصر يعني على في مؤشر
مدركات الفساد للاسف رقم 130 اما مؤشر
العداله وسياده القانون يبحث عنه اي
مستثمر اجنبي يريد ان يستثمر مصر رقم 136
139 دوله
الامور لا تشجع يعني الضوابط لابد ان يكون
هناك يعني اعاده هيكله قانونيه حمايه
للعماله وجود خطط حقيقيه للتنميه وتقييم
هذه الشركات
بقيم عادله يعني الخروج او تخرج المؤسسه
العسكريه من الاقتصاد سيجعل التنافسيه في
السوق المصري وسوق كبير وواعد مصر اكثر من
105 مليون اكثر من 11 مليون مغترب توجد
لدى مصر مقومات سياحيه وكذا قوه بشريه
كبيره من الممكن استخدامها للتصدير كما
يعني قلت التجربه المغربيه امامنا امامنا
يعني لدينا يعني الشعب المصري قريب جدا من
الشعب المغربي يستطيع ان تستطيع ان تصدر
مصر لا يعني لا يمكن اطلاقا ان نرى ان
الصادرات المصريه الغير البترونيه فقط 35
مليار دولار حين ان تركيا على سبيل المثال
254 مليار دولار لا يمكن ان يكون الحد
الادنى للاجور في مصر 90 دولار شهريا هذا
المشهد التي عملتها قليل هذا المشهد دكتور
مصطفى كيف سائل عاكس على المواطن المصري
الذي يعاني بالفعل من ارتفاع الاسعار الذي
عانى من التضخم الذي عانى من تعويم الجنيه
من قبل وهنالك الان مطالب بتعويم اكثر كيف
سنعكس كل ذلك على المواطن المصري
للاسف يعني التعويم الجديد قادم قادم كما
تفضل الضيف الكريم من القاهره
لقرابه الاربعين جنيه هذا سعره في السوق
الموازي المواطن المصري يئن لان ليس هناك
مصادر للعمله الاجنبيه يعني لا يوجد زياده
حقيقيه في الصادرات الغير بتروليه وكذا
غياب الشفافيه والوضوح سينعكس ذلك على
ازدياد في التضخم ازدياد في معدلات الفقر
ويعني الامر لم يتحسن الا بوجود خطط تنميه
حقيقيه مواجهه حقيقيه مع المشاكل الموجوده
لدينا تجارب تنمويه كثيره جدا الرئيس
المكسيكي على سبيل المثال
الذي ضع طائره الرئاسه التي اشتراها
يعني وقال انه سيقوم ببناء مستشفيات ينبغي
ان يتم بدلا من طرح هذه الشركات لو تم طرح
العاصمه الاداريه الجديده بكل مبانيها
للمستثمرين الاجانب وتم ضخ هذه الاموال في
صناعات صغيره وتنميه الصادرات سواء صادرات
زراعيه صدرات صناعيه ودعم كل الصناعات
الصغيره والشديد الصغر عماله
وتحرش وتحرك بالفن العجله الاقتصاديه لكن
دعنا نعود الى الكويت مره اخرى الى
المستشار علي العنيزي ايضا نلاحظ ان الدول
التي كانت تقدم دعما لمصر عن طريق الودائع
او حتى عن طريق شراء السندات الحكوميه
احجمت عن ذلك وبدات تطالب بشراء اصول
مقابل اموالها لماذا
بسبب طبيعي بسبب تراجع كبير في سعر الصرف
الجنيه المصري دائما عندما تقوم
بحقيقه للاستثمر او عمليه المبادرات
التجاريه تفقد جزء كبير من الامال بسبب
هذا التراجع المستمر لسعر صرف
الجنيه المصري بالتالي تتوقف الدول عن
الاستثمار حتى الافراد ايضا نحن الان
كافراد خليجيون موجودون في المنطقه لديه
هناك فرص كبيره في مصر الان سواء عقاريه
او صناعيه او زراعيه ايا كانت كل القطاعات
ولكن عندما تحسب هذا التراجع الكبير في
اسعار الصرف
يبدو لي انه في نهايه المطاف لن تعود براس
مالك لذلك الجميع ينتظر استقرار على الاقل
استقرار اسعار الصرف ثم بعد ذلك يبدا
بالعوده للاستثمار في مصر بما ان مصر دوله
لا نستطيع الاستطلاع عنها القاهره
مره اخرى الدكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب هل
مصر الان جاهزه لتعديل جديد لسعر الصرف
يعني نحن يعني سؤال في منتهى الصعوبه فعلا
يا استاذ زين يعني اذا استمرت الحكومه
المصريه على سياده سعر صرف الحاليه فهي لن
تستطيع ان توفي لا بتعودتها امام صندوق
النقد الدولي ولا حتى امام الشركاء
الدوليين واذا اتخذت هذا الاجراء ورفعت
سعر الصرف وانا يعني على فكره قلت انه قد
يقفز الى 40 الى خمسين اذا اتخذت هذه
الخطوه لن يتحمله
لاكثر من ذلك بكثير يعني
مقابل الدولار
يعني اذا قفزت اسعار البنك المركزي
الحاليه على اسعار الموجوده في السوق
الموازيه يعني سوق الموازيه الان نتحدث عن
38 وربما الى 40 اذا قفزت اسعار البنك
المركزي الرسميه على الاسعار الموجوده في
السوق الموازيه السوق الموازيه سوف تموت
لكن المشكله ان المواطن المصري الرابع
المستحيلات ان يتحمل وصول هذه الاسعار انت
تتحدث عن مواطن يعني لم يعد يستطيع ان
يوفر الاحتياجات الاساسيه لحياته اليوميه
باعتراف رئيس دوله رئيس مجلس الوزراء
عندما تحدث عن مشروع حياه وكريمه يقول انه
يستفيد منها حوالي 60% من الشعب المصري
وكان الرجل يعترف بان نسبه الفقر تقترب من
60% اذا كانت هذه البيانات الرسميه فما
بالك بالبيانات الحقيقيه ومن هنا يعني انا
في اعتقادي ان اداره سعر الصرف في مازق من
ربع المستحيلات يعني لا احد يستطيع ان
يتوقع ما سوف يحدث لكن مجريات الامور تقول
ان مصر لديها التزامات اتجاه صندوق النقد
الدولي والمؤشرات والمقالات تقول صندوق
متشدد الى ابعد مدى مع الحكومه المصريه
ولن يقبل على الاطلاق بالوعود يعني ينتظر
التنفيذ لن يقبل حتى بما تم الاعلان عنه
امس من
البيان المؤتمر الصحفي لدوله رئيس الوزراء
بانه سوف يتم عقد عقود وبيع بعض حصص اقليه
لمستثمرين المصريين وعرب لن يقبل بذلك لن
يقبل الا اذا تمت الصفقات بالفعل وتم نقل
هذه الاصول الى ملكيه سواء المستثمر
المصري او المستثمر الاجنبي ايضا لن يقبل
ما يسمى بتحرير سعر الصرف باستثناء قيمه
هذه الصفقات وهي مليار وتسعه مليون ما
الذي سيعود على المواطن المصري من هذه
الصفقات هذا التخارج وهذه وهذا البيع
للاصول هل يعود منه اي شيء للمواطن المصري
لانه الملكيه ستنتقل فقط من ملك الى ملك
ما الذي سيضاف فعليا الى الاقتصاد المصري
اذا كان هذه الصفقات من يعني نتائجها
تاجيل سعر تاجيل الاصلاحات المطلوبه في
سعر الصرف او وجود استقرار على الاقل لمده
عام في سعر الصرف انا اعتقد ان المواطن
المصري لن يدار ومن هنا سوف يعني تاتي
المنفعه من انه لن تضاف اليها اعباء ولا
اضرار جديده اما اذا يعني كانت هذه الخطوه
هي خطوه اوليه وتبعها بعد ذلك تحرير لسان
الصرف انا في اعتقادي ان
الاضرار سوف تكون مضاعفه على المواطن
المصري يعني
تمت هذه الصفقات نعم دكتور مصطفى من مشجن
كيف تتوقع ان ينعكس ذلك على المواطن
المصري
للاسف يعني اتوقع ان ينعكس يعني ذلك سلبيا
على المواطن المصري نحن امام مشهد الدولار
الامريكي كم سعر صرفه مع بدايه الجمهوريه
الجديده 6 جنيهات 35 في السوق الموازي
الان قرابه الاربعين جنيه حينما تنخفض
العمله تقريبا سته اضعاف او سبعه اضعاف
يرتفع معادلات الفقر فهذا امر ينذر بموقف
مبابي ونتمنى ان تعود الحكومه المصريه الى
اجراءات اصلاحيه حقيقيه تنهض بالتعليم
والصحه وزياده الصادرات حتى حتى يستوي
الاقتصاد المصري شكرا جزيلا شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور مصطفى البحث في التمويل الدوليه
والدراسات الاقتصاديه ونشكر ضيفنا من
الكويت المستشار الاقتصادي على العنيزي
ومن القاهره الدكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب
استاذ الاقتصاد السياسي هو خبير الاقتصاد
الدولي
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
[موسيقى]